my man when I was growing up I was in a
dance group with this girl and this girl
was the most sexiest hot girl and he
always went on about that and I went out
with I went I met her over the couple of
weekends ago and I said yeah I saw you
go he goes oh she looks so far you know
what I mean and I showed him a picture
of her not a video it went awful he said
to me you know what right you've upset
me all the next day he was talking about
it I couldn't sleep all the next day she
went from like a 68 year old to like a
size 20 well and he couldn't believe
that he's the same person I said I look
a lot better in your eyes now didn't I
but I never had no problem with him
looking at other women because I know
that we're coming into our racing that
was your crush back then that's why I
was happy to show him that women let
themselves go they've always got so much
to talk about the men but when they get
to a certain age they let themselves go
and they still expect to get the same
men yeah where's nine times out I don't
keep up they don't keep up the energy
they don't keep it up